hey it's Justine and today we are
checking out this yoga Pro 9i laptop
the display is a 14 and a half inch
touchscreen mini LED it's incredibly
thin coming in at 16.7 millimeters it
has this new beautiful tidal teal color
and an Nvidia 4070 all in the super
small and compact design thanks to
Lenovo for partnering with me on this
video now let's unbox it
there's another box inside of this box
this is the new title teal color too
it's so pretty
look at that I like that it's not too
overpowering but it's also like a subtle
and now is the fun part the setup the
first thing you'll notice is how awesome
this display is it's 3K with 165 Hertz
adaptive refresh rate that gives you
sharp smooth and high-end color
reproduction and accuracy this is so
great for not only watching content on
but if you're working in a field where
colors matter this is key it's powered
by a 13th generation Intel Core I9
processor up to 64 gigs of RAM and one
terabyte of storage it also has a 75
watt hour battery with rapid charge and
an Nvidia 4070 for powerful Graphics
this can be configured in a 16 inch
version as well but I have recently been
trying to minimize my tech footprint so
this 14 and a half is perfect for me I
can't even tell you how obsessed with
this color I am like it's so beautiful
this new title teal color is lenovo's
new signature color signifying
sustainability of their new premium
ecosystem of yoga devices there is a 5
megapixel built-in camera with a webcam
privacy shutter I love that this is
becoming something that many laptop
manufacturers are including to protect
our privacy as for ports we have an HDMI
2.1 a full-size SD card reader one Intel
Thunderbolt 4 Port one USBC two USB a
and an audio combo Jack board it also
has Lenovo X power which is a
proprietary Custom Performance Tuning
solution that is designed to maximize
performance in its ultra thin design
this gives you a hardware Boost Plus a
software accelerator to speed up
software previews rendering and exports
portability is something that is so
important for me but I never want to
sacrifice power or battery life for
something smaller I'm at the coffee shop
I'm actually going to edit some of the
footage that we've been shooting for
this video the other thing is I didn't
even bring a charger because I love how
great the battery life is on this I
don't normally add it in Premiere but I
love the fact that this is so powerful
that I literally can edit on the go I'm
not even plugged into power and I still
have a ton of battery life left also did
I mention how much I love having the SD
card reader so great
I love this new keyboard so much they
did a little redesign of not only the
keyboard to give the keys more travel
but they even enlarge the trackpad now I
really want to test out this camera and
the noise canceling microphones so I'm
going to give my sister a call and see
what's up let's see if she answers I'm
scared we just got back from traveling
so I know she's exhausted hi oh my gosh
are you back in the office now
back in the office yeah well no I'm
about to go work out okay yeah I just
saw you're out of office and I was like
we need to have a very important meeting
yeah well back in office for this 2 50
p.m meeting and then and then I gotta go
work out are we recording the podcast
later yeah the most important question
is do you think we're gonna get dinner
after the podcast yes like yes dinner
yes I think I really want a salmon salad
so I think maybe we order from that
place that I always get a salmon salad
from yeah I think that's a good yeah
we're eating on the podcast we could I
mean we don't have to okay no so now I'm
gonna test out a processor intensive
game to see how it runs and I also love
that I can connect a controller to this
I'm not gonna lie I like playing with
the controller so feel free to judge I
don't care I'm gonna play how I want to
play We're witnessing something that
could be life-changing right now
this plays well
like right now when I travel I carry two
laptops I carry one specifically for
gaming and then one for work this could
literally change my life
hello oh gosh this is this is running so
good not gonna lie this is actually
running better than some higher end
gaming laptops that I have that are
specifically made for gaming
and I'm freaking fast dude
I'm so happy right now so I've been
having so much fun with this laptop so
far like it's honestly so impressive how
small it is and how much I can actually
do on this right now I'm working on some
Lightroom edits with all of these photos
that I have this is from a shoot with my
iJustine pink cables so we have a ton of
these photos so let's just do a quick
little edit to show you how responsive
it is here we go editing some highlights
of those Shadows
Down the Lights exposure there we go
look at that you're looking good the
Lightroom can definitely be processor
intensive depending upon the type of
photos that you have so obviously these
are all Raw photos and it's happening
pretty quickly so I'm definitely
impressed the other thing that I do a
ton of and I'm sure I'm not alone is
just doing executive work like checking
my email writing scripts paying bills
doing all of those things so having
something where I can just do the most
basic tasks possible but also if I need
to hop in edit a photo edit a video I
can do that as well
so far I've absolutely loved testing out
this laptop and I do test out so many
here on my channel and it's been a while
since I've been this impressed I also
really love the display it is a touch
screen which I feel like now there
shouldn't be a computer that isn't a
touch display there's just something
about being able to just quickly tap if
you want to do something or interact
with your device and I really really
like that the display is also very
Crystal Clear like even just watching
content on here it all just looks really
great again this is the 14 and a half
inch version so they do have a 16 inch
display but this 14 inch especially for
me is such a perfect size
do you hear those speakers I mean it's
hard for you guys to hear it because
you're hearing me watching a video of
you watching a video of me watching a
video of trying to you know what I mean
so this is my own video so I know what
it should sound like so now that we're
in
order thing is so spacious and that was
one of the things I was most excited
about and it gives you yeah this sounds
great where you should charge depending
it sounds really nice
foreign
oh yeah
this is up at 100
[Applause]
[Music]
and this is a 34 which is probably where
I would normally have it
[Music]
sounds pretty good I'm the kind of
person that loves to edit with computer
speakers I don't like wearing headphones
I like to edit just on a device I just I
don't know I'm not sure why but that's
what I like so I'm definitely glad to
know that these speakers sound really
good
thank you guys so much for watching this
was such a fun video and I am so excited
about this device not only is it super
powerful but I am just I can't get over
this color I actually was getting so
many compliments when I was out and
about I didn't make it but I wish I did
anyway if you guys would like to get
more information about this device I
will put a link in the description I
look forward to seeing what you guys
think of this don't forget to like
comment and subscribe and be sure to hit
the Bell to be notified when I post new
videos I'll see you guys in the next one
bye